By now it should be clear that
successful management of chronic
diseases in our highly specialized
healthcare system requires
digital data that can be shared as
needed to achieve coordinated care.
However, patient-specific healthcare
data is highly sensitive,
and is protected by a law called HIPAA,
which calls for
severe penalties, including prison time,
for failure to properly
secure what is called
Protected Health Information or PHI.
PHI is healthcare data that is linked to
information that identifies the patient.
You will hear the term de-identified
data which refers to the same health
information once it has been separated
from any fields that could directly or
indirectly be used to
identify the patient.
Everyone in healthcare is
concerned about HIPAA.
So the topic of this lesson are the
critical technologies that secure
PHI to make sure it is only shared for
legitimate purposes and
even then, the sharing has been approved
by the patient or their legal designee.